ah j'en vois un peu plus
jouer à la manière de Molière l'une des
15 catégories sur lesquelles planches
ces jeunes de Déclic Théâtre pour le
Mondial d'improvisation junior pour se
faire un atelier hebdomadaire de deux
heures pour laisser place à l'imaginaire
car l'impro ça ne se prépare pas
actuellement on travaille la catégorie
Shakespeare aujourd'hui la selle de
Molière et en plus on va continuer de
travailler de répéter en fait c'est pas
une répétition parce que l'improvisation
peut pas refaire ce qu'on a ce qu'on
vient de faire parce que c'est
l'imagination ça laisse place à notre
imagination vraiment l'impro alors que
le théâtre classique enfin tu es moins
libre alors qu'à l'impro tu es vraiment
qui tu veux et tout ça je trouve ça je
trouve que c'est bien du 23 au 26
février à Trappes c'est si jeunes de 15
à 18 ans représenteront la France face
au Québec à la Belgique et à la Suisse
bonjour monsieur
voyez-vous j'ai un chapeau des détective
j'ai le pose ici et puis une pipe vous
êtes effectué je suis détective
effectivement une loupe ils ont été
sélectionnés au sein de la troupe des
juniors de Déclic Théâtre par leur coach
dont la comédienne Amel Amziane
donc si lui il s'avance de ce côté-là
toi tu en profite pour aller t'avancer
de ce côté-là et là de son côté sur la
capitaine de l'équipe de France si il y
a des problèmes avec l'arbitre Nono je
serai là s'il y a des problèmes bah
entre nous enfin en interne on va dire
je serai là je serais un peu la maman du
groupe je m'occupais des de mes
coéquipiers et tout ça va être cool
c'est un joli melting-pot autant sur les
parcours des unes et des uns tant sur
les origines
yvelinoise et temps sur les années
d'improvisation donc finalement on a des
gens qui qui reviennent à l'impro dans
cette équipe on a des on a des personnes
qui en font depuis maintenant huit ans
donc il y a un joyeux mélange dans cette
équipe et on va voir ce que ça donnera
sur la patinoire à partir du 23 février
l'année dernière en Suisse les juniors
de Déclic Théâtre avaient décroché la
deuxième place derrière la Belgique le
titre est jouable pour cette édition à
domicile mais le Mondial d'un pro c'est
avant tout un moment de partage Cédric
rencontré les des Suisses des Belges et
québécois c'est vrai que ça va être ça
va être quelque chose surtout que on va
se découvrir c'est pas du tout le même
personnalité les gens qu'on rencontre
dans la patinoire ça ça devient des
vrais amis même s'ils habitent au Canada
en Belgique ou en Suisse donc d'abord le
fait de prendre du plaisir et ensuite si
on arrive deuxième ou premier on va pas
on va pas cracher dessus d'entrer la
France affrontera la Belgique au
Conservatoire de Musique et de Danse le
23 février le Mondial d'improvisation
s'achèvera le 26 février une finale au
programme à la Meurice de Trappes vous
êtes tous les mêmes
[Applaudissements]